what what the hell oh my god oh yeah
that's right what hey Bob
Oh God Oh God oh geez mark what are you
doing huh I got way up no I blew you up
oh good I feel less embarrassed are we
supposed to kill each other or oh no yes
oh yeah I guess a new game has started
I'm not sure though no no no that's just
the end oh here oh I'm pretty sure a new
game started I don't know what makes me
think oh what did I get
Oh my dead body he's just sitting there
oh I don't used to grapple yeah oh my
gosh or jump jump again it lasers to
where you can jump there you go Oh
father okay papa oh yeah Oh God in my
own mind I did that oh hey get your
heads in the game this time Mac maybe
Wow
whoop whoa no whoa where am I why am I
here oh yeah fellow's dead Oh God
okay run away Oh
I'm gonna call you quick-draw Oh I kill
so many of you and then Wade is a dick
ha ha ha ha you know what you did Wade
God ha ha ha oh yes yes yes bring it on
you [ __ ] come here [ __ ] it was
afraid hey how did you kill me ah this
game god this game is the worst kind of
ball oh it's gonna destroy our
friendship probably I'm
without them and weren't that close
anyway come near me happy bras come near
me I see that [ __ ] mine you put down
you [ __ ] come at me bro a lifetime of
pain
wait oh I thought the bonds blow
yourselves head for this
no Marty sniper to me oh you're
beautiful
[ __ ] Oh marks a sneaky sniper yeah he's
taking on us oh I've got em oh no no
tell anyone she's a secret
yeah I'm marks a sea snake
Jack what are you doin hey uh hey wait
come over here ah up top up top up top
Oh hammering wait things wait wait um I
would go with the hamper Oh is your hot
poop yeah you're hot is poop let's
goggle the eyes ha ha Shane oh [ __ ] I
don't have a gun I don't have a gun I
don't have a gun oh no house you watched
him are you out of come here well let me
row no I'm not a gun I found one yet
damn it okay oh how was I the only one
that died in that exchange [ __ ] you guys
I died no you died after the fact
oh [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] you're so [ __ ]
Jam I know ha ha ha what huh dad oh oh
no oh why did I go that's that's not
yeah we shouldn't have gone out god oh
no I should have done that get the 2e I
got him I got him Bob I got him
mark I don't repeat no no I got him I
got him I got now I got you I'm gonna
get you again [ __ ] us all of your flat
boy they're fired in there hey I didn't
realize the hammer was gonna make me
five the map
ah the creator pot or waiter rather
winning this whoo oh [ __ ] I think I won
more than three do you think you really
think what I want to get in game see you
select reject yeah oh god oh god oh if I
hadn't a panicked like a freaking idiot
I might have been okay there oh [ __ ]
damn you jack oh [ __ ]
how how how [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
stuck with that turkey leg shut up
whoa oh no oh how did that kill me oh it
was a grenade yeah but I was far away
from it whoa whoa no no no [ __ ] oh God
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Bob here come here bro yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a new person's
game imma be totally positive about
everything
everything's totally fair oh no [ __ ] not
[ __ ] uh-huh okay right now Bob oh no
no that was totally legitimate you did
great Bob always killing so oh god oh
god oh no
goodbye Oh quick around no hahahahaha
come here you
son of a [ __ ] you cheating bastard oh
god oh god oh god that's a good map I
like my guys no it's not I'm destroying
yoga I doing also good no please please
no no please bark
bur oh oh god oh god whoa oh oh oh whoa
oh oh no no okay no I can't get to Bob
I'll give you later
oh [ __ ] here Bob I him he no that was
totally legitimate it was my fault you
deserve to live you deserve to live
you're the better player obviously Oh
God
[ __ ] you Bob yep no no Bob is totally
not cheating there we go God he was
Annette I don't know what you know no no
I was trying to get to you that's the
thing I was obvious not I know it was
the net God you think I'm a [ __ ]
idiot no of course I knew was the best
God look at me look at me happy than
that Oh God sneaky [ __ ] hello oh god oh
god what the [ __ ] for fur balls oh no my
carpet you dive on yeah you killed me
well oh that would've been a nice little
breaks for me max got off - oh God yeah
oh god oh god oh no whoa what the
I got your head mark [ __ ] you it's
totally fair and legitimately good game
always
it's awesome you're such a douche you
deserve that 5-it bun yes I'm having a
lot of fun so you won't Dookie okay I
still want to played okay
I got this okay I got this hi guys Bob
wasn't such a cheating prick I would be
in first
Bob how does it feel to be the weight of
the game don't hate me because I'm
beautiful
oh I don't trust me that's an I hate you
for Matty [ __ ] reason ah [ __ ] oh no I
mean nothing nothing here huh oh Jesus
Jesus oh you just do that I don't know
is that you Bob yeah you and I just
killed each other
Oh killed each other I thought you blow
yeah oh he wasn't moving why was I
moving Oh [ __ ] idiot whoa whoa whoa
whoa so keep doing it you're gonna mark
oh oh you're sore at me
oh I ain't know anything really good and
he killed you oh god oh god no no that
gun takes a while to charge up he threw
a sword and that's what killed uh Oh Oh
fire Jack how the [ __ ] don't that you
may miss you a mine oh mine on the
ground oh you should have minded your
step
I should have minded my own business hey
ha ha congratulations sir thank you sir
I this game is awesome
and I love it by that you're beginning
to appreciate how legitimately awesome
this game is thank you
hahaha always various gun you didn't
actually she's no good get him Oh like a
lot of gun are your gun you fool I was
just standing there
ah sadly rifle oh oh is it we did it
wait
Oh
oh is that life no hey do you have to
hold the pin I didn't pull the pen [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll do it mark I
believe in you do what oh no all the
things okay kid ready for this aren't
you down charges get them Meryl it's a
Spartan gun Oh God oh Jesus hahaha uh
where am I
Oh have fun you keep shooting that you
look like a crazy mistake oh jesus oh
God
hey Jack
hi dad walking on good good I smoked
this run haha no I shot you [ __ ] I don't
know I had you Oh sweets let's pray ah
oh no not what I wanted what's up what
help what happened wait Jack wait what
happened there
yeah I push you and you hit the bouncy
Patten flew off huh
no no no I shot you with the net and
somehow I got netted what the hell
happened well oh oh you didn't have a
net not from my camera I blasted it you
okay okay I got you okay
Oh God whoa whoa we're just having a fun
little nest game here anyways you want
to go wait how the [ __ ] do I guess
exactly wow really
gorilla Bob I really didn't seal the
deal there you could have done a whole
lot better though hey Bob you'd show
yacht short at the end there oh my
goodness oh [ __ ]
well yeah
it's like a dig okay I want one
ah now that this game is becoming more
fair whoa
Bob's destroying us I appreciate what
I'm talking about
whoa whoa oh yeah mark am I saying games
and fair games a bunch of bull I never
said that I you can't quote me on that
but yeah this game is the worst kind of
ball Matt anything I've said already but
hell we're posting this to no no Matt
edit all their videos out
I didn't delete their channels well
let's not be hasty stop you hate it here
what oh sorry about hi know what's uh
what's everybody doing good Jack hang it
out someone going for the minigun or not
I was not got it Mike Forbes there's
orcs
no that's my corpse oh you're shooting
correctly is the problem what I really
want to know is how in the hell you see
yeah
wait what is this whoa everywhere I
literally landed on oh that's Wade [ __ ]
god damn it Jack no it's really
depressing wait is literally only women
there you go out nice grenade whoa
[ __ ] you dude up the water crowd I could
go there bad I would have laughed at
that didn't count
oh Jesus oh I don't want to go out there
[ __ ] you guys oh oh no come here you are
getting dark Oh No
so we gotta mark
nice Jesus no no no no no no no no no I
need adult I needed help I needed uh uh
no how about no I'm gonna say oh you
literally shot his head off oh man I was
defenseless in that corner that was like
nothing I could get well I got a flower
I got a fire fire fire fire I'm not a
[ __ ] cool oh okay I'm so lucky I
saved you thank you thank you I hate you
Bob I hate you so much
oh no good II didn't win all the quote
no wait oh I thought you're going for
the other one
oh don't why oh jeez
all right Golden Gun tennis a for sure I
didn't think I picked up a shoe instead
of the gun oh my god up in Canada game
my mistake was bringing a shooter that
of that s don't question me Jackie you
selling a crazy old lady no oh
enjoying yourself there very much so yes
okay I got that awesome bye thanks bye
oh I got a flower tea I don't need a key
efore take a dart gun you douche all of
it I'm glad I'm not the only one oh no
oh oh I gotta go oh how did you want it
I kill them that's no in my screen visit
the words gets weird in my screen yeah
in my screen I had the
shotgun oh yeah in my screen I have the
shotgun and I shot you oh yeah oh [ __ ]
you got to reload that jack reload that
oh I didn't know I went through the
glass it goes to the it goes through
pretty much everything I think all right
Wade one like what again wait wait say
it again
I think Wade one oh I think way back I
think they had one Morgan aliyou ah
that's Barry wait wait you want one each
time Jack good job yeah oh man wait like
man do you have the perfect strategy
because what you do is you just like go
right into a corner and wait until
everyone kills themself and then come in
and scoop up all the glory use it
because I screw up my jobs to the kick
hitting your head I got the trophy
too bad cuz I've got another ideas it's
wrong